[Music]  Kylie Jenner is doing everything she can  to keep her baby bump under wraps the  reality star and her sisters Kourtney  Kim khloé  and Kendall posed it up for the latest  Calvin Klein underwear ads and if you  look closely the 20 year old manages not  to show too much skin while her siblings  are photographed in several shots  topless and in their undies look at that  bud Kylie always has her abdomen hidden  either with a blanket her hand or a  shirt et has learned that the photo  shoot took place in October not long  after we confirmed that she's expecting  her first child with boyfriend rapper  Travis Scott the beauty mogul also stays  covered up in a video ad for the brand  where the sisters play a game of never  have I ever never have I ever gotten a  tattoo  [Music]  [Music]